je suis très surprise quand on parle
d'auto détermination et qu'à côté de ça
on parle d'alliance transatlantique pour
la simple et bonne raison qu une
alliance transatlantique en fait c'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on est extrêmement dépendant des
services et l union alors après on peut
dire plutôt qu'on les des clients pour
le court une colonie numérique des états
unis car mon on peut le dire comme ça
bon quand on parle peu thermique
détermination ça voudrait dire qu'on ne
saurait pas dépendante du coût
d'infrastructure et la fois logiciel ou
soc
or aujourd'hui les gaffes à moi j'aime
bien plutôt appeler les big tech 1 ou
par de plus en plus important sur les
infrastructures comme les câbles sous
marins par exemple les câbles
sous-marins c'est plus de 90% de
l'activité numérique aujourd'hui ça
passe pas par le ciel ça passe bien par
les océans et et dans cette industrie du
câble sous marin
au départ les acteurs traditionnels par
exemple c'est les télécommunications et
les états aujourd'hui ce sont les gars
and soul in tech
ce sont google à microsoft d'une
certaine façon ainsi facebook et amazon
qui construit de leur propre câble
aujourd'hui on est sur une dimension
très différente de celle de simple
fournisseur de services logiciels
même chose pour les infrastructures du
coup de constellation satellitaire
tout à l'heure nous parlait du cou de
dede constellation satellitaire du
projet qui part d'amazon est aujourd'hui
en fait quand on regarde ce qui se passe
au sol au niveau des technologies cloud
en fait microsoft google amazon
construisent l'infrastructure logicielle
qui est relié en fait assez
constellation satellitaire
en fait ils sont en train de prendre une
place bien bien plus importante que
celle qu'ils avaient aujourd'hui et
qu'il se passe c'est que nos acteurs
proches les télécoms par exemple que ce
soit orange ou d'autres lecteurs de
telekom en allemagne au fonds des
partenariats stratégiques avec des
entreprises pour gérer les réseaux
saljic
donc on rentre dans une autre dimension
aujourd'hui nos dépendances
[Musique]